et avec henri sterdyniak chercheur
affilié à l'oas et aux membres des
économistes atterrés
bonsoir en avouant henri sterdyniak
alors on attend des annonces
ça fait quand même plusieurs semaines
qu'on attend colline européenne
s'accordent à cordes en tout cas que
tous ses membres accordent leurs violons
sur ce plan de relance aujourd'hui et
justement il ya des discussions qu
faut-il en attendre
normalement c'est le jour où elle il
faudrait aboutir ainsi peu si on veut
que le plan de relance aurait mis en
place de mettre suffisamment rapide le
problème c'est dans l'union européenne à
27 me et que des 27 dans un 4 ils sont
traités parmi l'état y en a inquiété du
ce et les pays bas donc comme il faut
l'unanimité il ya un blog car alors
justement on va rappeler justement ce
qui divise les états frugaux d'un côté
il ya les pays-bas la suède au danemark
l'autriche
et puis de l'autre côté la france
l'allemagne
oui c'est à dire que la france et
l'allemagne et surtout l'italie et
l'espagne sont d'accord pour un vaste
plan de relance de 750 milliards dont
500 milliards seraient des dons de
l'union européenne aux pays en
difficulté et 250 milliards seraient est
prêt le problème c'est que les pays hugo
refus des tapas dont et donc souhaite
pas uniquement des prêts que avec des
prêts l'italie et l'espagne serait de
plus en plus endettés et par ailleurs
les pays bas veulent que toutes les
décisions de des dons ni en difficulté
soit adoptée par les à l'unanimité donc
que les pays bas est en quelque sorte un
droit de veto et demandent en échange de
ce plan daide les pays s'engagent à des
réformes structurelles en particules
biais de leur système de retraite
oui de leurs systèmes de droit du
travail et bien sûr difficilement
acceptable pour les pays aidés
donc on a un blocage les lié au fait que
les décisions doivent être prises à
l'unanimité
alors qu révèle justement ces blocages
sur l'état aujourd'hui le de l'union
européenne à l'union européenne des 27
pays avec chacun ses intérêts c'est sa
vision des choses et la solidarité a du
mal à se mettre en place il ya des pays
qui sont très frappé par la pandémie
comme l'italie comme l'espagne des pays
amis cran la crise de migrants comme la
grèce l'italie l'espagne l'un des pays
qui sont moins par ap mais qui veulent
pas l'aider est actuellement en entrant
dans des discussions de marchands de
tapis
est-ce que ce matin il était question
d'accorder à rabais au 4 rue go pour
qu'ils axent le plan c'est à dire que on
accepterait une paye oif
que vaut une cour le budget européen ce
qui sera tout à fait tout à fait bizarre
et dans ce pareil pour d'autres pays les
pays de l'est acceptent le plan à
condition d'être aidés alors qu'eux
mêmes sont très peu frappé par la
pandémie
donc c'est très difficile d'arriver à un
accord à 27 6 les pays non pas un peu le
sens de la solidarité et aussi il faut
dire le sens de leurs intérêts parce que
l'allemagne a bien compris que c'est
elle le grand bénéficiaire de l'union
européenne puisque ça lui permette de
faire des gains de compétitivité
important et les pays bas devraient le
comprendre aussi parce que grâce à
l'union européenne c'est quand même un
port à centre de passage extrêmement
important dans l'union dos rond les pays
bas profitent énormément de la
construction européenne merci beaucoup
avoue henri sardines
que d'avoir répondu en direct à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
chercheur affilié à l'oas et aux membres
des économistes atterrés
merci à vous